one of the speakers her dream job is to
be a children's librarian
you can ask her about any book she's up
to 70 so far this year halfway through
the year 70 books
and the other speaker Who besides loving
cooler bags
loves to travel which I guess the cooler
bag would be great because he's trying
to visit all 50 states and he has six to
go
pretty close to the goal so everyone
please welcome Molly and Andrew
um Andrew and I are super happy to be
here I'm Molly Huey I'm the team lead
for data legal analytics and business at
Bloomberg law if you've been here for a
couple years I've spoken at the last
couple of conferences and Jared reached
out and he said hey can you come this
year and I said great what would you
like me to talk about he said data
journalism and I said no but Andrew can
so yes hi I'm Andrew I am a data
reporter at Bloomberg Industry Group so
I work with reporters across our
Newsroom to tell stories with data and
it's great to be here especially because
I actually started our about four or
five years ago learning from Jared at a
boot camp he came to our company and
that was my introduction and so I never
would have thought I would be here for
five years later actually given a talk
so this is very special great
so what are we going to talk about we
are going to give more of a high level
view about how to take some of the
principles that we use with data
journalism to guide the projects that
you do when you go from something like
this some XML some hard to read data to
something like this where it's a
polished finished presentation that
tells a story in a very short succinct
way so I'm gonna give it to the survey
person to conduct a little survey okay
how many of you have been drinking
already today
no you are not taking advantage of our
speaker bartenders do more really how
how many of you write about the data
that you are working with
for non-technical audience okay okay
half two-thirds not bad so we're going
to take you through some of that process
because in data journalism we're not
writing for a technical audience we're
not doing academic papers we're not
doing
um any kind of technical writing really
so that code that Andrew showed on the
last night is the only code we're going
to show you
you're welcome so how do we interrogate
data like a journalist exactly and so
and and not only how but why and so one
of the first reasons that you want to
bring some of these principles into the
work that you do is because it gives you
a layered understanding of the data that
you're working with so you want to be
able to get really specific nitty-gritty
talk about the technicals of how you did
something why you did something but then
also distill that down to a simpler
Forum where you can talk to a broader
audience about what you're doing and so
that goes to the next point is that it
makes your data approachable you want to
be able to have your data uh accessible
to the widest variety of people and
finally that also makes it easier to
justify the work that you're doing when
you can distill something down to the
simplest forms you're able to really
have a better understanding of how you
did something and why you did it and you
can back up what you've been doing like
a journalist like a journalist but
before we're able to do that we first
have to get our data so internal data
external data My Team Works mostly with
internal data and because we're
Bloomberg that includes the Bloomberg
terminal it includes the universe of
federal dockets filings it includes a
global patents database but it also
includes surveys which my team does a
lot of so that's the internal data we
work with you mostly and then in The
Newsroom we don't often have the benefit
of being able to do our own data
construction where we're actually
putting together our own data we're
relying on data that's already been
collected already been produced by
government agencies ngos companies and
so we have to work with what we're given
and that comes with a few different
challenges so each each has some pros
and cons that we're going to talk about
with the next step which is vetting the
data which is especially when you're
dealing with this external data so
important you have to understand exactly
what it is that you're looking at and so
when it comes to vetting the data what
we usually do is make sure we understand
the format that it's coming in so this
applies to a variety of different things
right so with numbers are we talking
hundreds thousands millions billions
don't just assume uh whatever is on a
spreadsheet is you know the real number
always be sure to put in that extra work
to understand the format if it's uh if
it's dates like we saw earlier for
quarters that might be shown in a
specific way so always understand the
format that data is coming in and take
some steps to actually get get through
that and then also you want to do some
spot checks you want to make sure if
there's any outliers in the data if
there's there's stuff that's missing go
through do some quick summary statistics
to see what it is that you're looking at
holistically and then that goes to the
final Point as well make no assumptions
and Molly's got a reason why yes so even
when we ask people to self-report their
data as in surveys they're people that
get it wrong
um years ago my team used to run in a
yearly HR survey we would ask HR
directors everything about their
practices their department and we'd have
a series of
numerical input boxes that say you know
what is your Department's budget what's
your whole organization's budget because
we'd run some ratios and you know HR
directors would see if they're getting
more less than the average
every year there were people that
overshot their their Department budget
by multiples of 10. it's like your
department budget is not 10 times the
entire organization budget pretty sure
so even with internal data you got to do
these spot checks you got to vet it uh
any kind of data always be taking these
steps but now once we've we've gotten
our data we've vetted it we understand
generally what is happening with it
um it's time to write about it and this
is some of the steps that you can take
to make sure that you're writing about
it clearly and not making any mistakes
when you do that right because about
two-thirds of you said you were writing
about data so you're probably already
doing this but given that it's a high
level presentation this is what you can
do this is what you can take back if
you're training somebody else to write
on data
right and so you want to make sure that
you're rounding appropriately with the
data you want to describe things in real
words and if there's one thing to take
away from this presentation it's just
about making things approachable and
using real world examples to try and
take your data to the next level so
people can actually understand what it
is that you're doing and so it's
important to you know generalize a
little bit sometimes with data or you
can say about a quarter or just over
half and we generally do better talking
about rates versus percentages so for
example it's better to say you know one
in five New Yorkers versus about 20 of
the New York population it's easier to
visualize one than it is the other and
then also another thing to keep in mind
as well is just seasonality if you're
dealing especially with labor data or
any time series data to to know if there
are going to be fluctuations in the data
that you're working with and if that's
already accounted for because you want
to be sure that you're describing that
correctly
yep yep and so this is just a real world
example that comes from our Newsroom
from uh one of our great reporters Laura
Mahoney who did a story on a complicated
issue of taxes sales tax
um and so this has to do with this quirk
in California tax where for online sales
it comes from the the sales tax the
local sales tax goes to where the
transaction occurred not where the
customer is located that's buying the
product and so because of this uh cities
have struck deals with companies where
they will put their distribution centers
in their city and then the city will
give some of the money back to the
company as an incentive for doing that
and so this is one of the ways that we
describe what's happening here so danuba
this is a city in California receives
one percent of the sales price which is
the local share of the total sales tax
the city then shares its portion with
Best Buy 50 and lawyer Roberts and dejas
10 so none of that's wrong that's all
factually what is happening but it's
hard to wrap your head around that so
what we did and you can see that this is
actually the text that we use to support
this graphic to give that that very
nitty-gritty
um wording for what is actually going on
but then we talk about it in real terms
that people can understand and wrap
their hands or heads around more easily
so we give the example where there's a
consumer they purchase a 100 item at
Best Buy they get charged seven dollars
and 25 cents in sales tax and then 625
that goes to the state and County a
dollar of that sales tax goes to the
city of danuba Best Buy 50 cents goes
back to them and then 10 cents goes to
this lawyer who actually wrote this deal
that's getting really rich
the transaction yes good on him so that
was like one of the that was one of the
major takeaways from the story as well
is that this lawyer was getting a lot of
money from this deal that was struck and
does this remind anybody of Jessica's
talk where it's like you're crediting
the first thing the last that all these
things go sideways but at least this
makes it really understandable because
that's tough exactly yeah so give real
world examples when you can and it helps
people understand better Okay so we've
gathered our data we've vetted our data
we've written about our data Andrew just
showed you a really good visualization
but really kind of the last step before
you publish something is you're going to
visualize something right because that's
how our brains work visualizations allow
us to take in a lot of information in a
small space in a small time so
we have on my team a fabulous graphic
designer that does most of our work and
his tagline is don't be wrong don't be
confusing so in the previous example all
the words written out it wasn't wrong
but it was confusing you couldn't do
anything with it and so then you know
that infographic helped with that a lot
exactly and then again use appropriate
chart types right the infographic work
for that because you had to show so many
things going around but you know I think
at this point we all know when to use
pies almost never when to use bar charge
line charts all those kinds of things so
right and then always be sure to include
your source with the visualization and
this goes right into the next point
which is you want your visualizations to
be able to stand alone uh so like that
last graphic that we showed we were able
to show it to you and it was able to
make sense because it had a headline it
had a description it had a source all
the material was there so make sure that
your visualizations can tell a story on
their own they don't rely on stuff
that's either in a report or in a story
that's nearby to make sense of it one of
the things we always say is if somebody
does a save as or prints out just your
visual
that should make sense by itself the
copy surrounding it should be the extra
the context and that you shouldn't
duplicate in both parts if it's in your
graphic it doesn't need to be in your
text and if it's in your text it
probably doesn't need to be in your
graphic unless it's kind of headline top
level material right right and to
illustrate our point we present to you
bad Graphics these ones are terrible
please don't ever do this
um you know pies within donuts and pies
that add to not 100 and
this violates wrong and confusing I'm
pretty sure on a couple of levels
please don't just please don't
all right so this is where I go all
inside the actor studio and start asking
Andrew
what is his wish list so
if I am a person that has a compendium
of data that you would like to use as a
journalist what would you like me to do
yes and so thankfully we're in a room
with a lot of people that are producing
data for people like me that actually
analyze it and many of you already do
these things but if you don't please
spread the word help others to start
taking these uh start doing this as well
so the first thing is please have a data
dictionary uh detailed explanation of
the data fields and what is going on so
that I can actually fully understand
what is what is happening and not make
any of those assumptions or not have to
pick up the phone and call you and go
through a detailed explanation of how
you collected something
what else and then next is have if I do
have to contact you maybe you maybe I
still have questions even uh if you do
have that detailed data dictionary
um have a clear point of contact uh for
who is in charge of the data at your
company or organization and ideally this
won't just be a press person who doesn't
understand what's happening with the
data but someone who actually put
together uh what it is I'm looking at so
that I can reach out to you and I love
to whenever I'm dealing with external
data if I have a project idea in mind
and a way I'm going to go about doing
that project to talk to whoever it is
that created this data set to say hey
this is what I'm thinking of doing with
your data this is how I'm thinking of
analyzing it does that make sense and
I've had times where people have come
back and said no you can't really make
that you you can't say that because it's
not there in the data it's not how we
collected it or for whatever reason and
so that's extremely helpful to be able
to have those conversations and to make
sure one that that you're aware that I'm
using your data and that it's out there
and two that I'm actually using it
correctly okay
and the next is just being transparent
about when the data was updated and if
it's still being updated that's not
always clear and so it's great to have
that just
plane and and next to the data current
as of yes done continued because the
wish list is longer yes and so there's
more this is a big one and this has
become big during the pandemic
especially we've seen uh with public
health agencies where they have been
locking data behind dashboards and can I
jump in with a bad dashboard Okay so
if any of you all care anything about
Law Firm diversity we're about to
release a very big Law Firm diversity
project on Monday and as part of this I
was going through the submissions that
we got from law firms and I wanted to
say how many of the firms that submitted
data to us are part of the amla 200
which is like the biggest highest
revenue firms in the country
easy to find locked in Tableau it's
great I could scroll the Tableau I had
to go through all my submissions and
like line by line by line are they in
this Tableau dashboard it was a pain in
the butt please let your data be
downloadable yes so please it makes it
so much easier and some for some
government agencies they've been using
this kind of as a run around to say you
know we're fulfilling our obligations
under foia we're giving you the
information it's right there
but you can't do anything with it it's
all locked up and it looks pretty and
it's really usable for the average
consumer yeah so there's the okay that's
fine but if there's a point of contact
we could reach out and say hey look we'd
actually like the data behind this and
that would make it easier but was there
a point of contact nope
and then finally and I don't think any
of you do this on this room but tidy up
your data if it is not already I hate
spreadsheets that have 70 plus columns
especially when you're analyzing stuff
year over year and some of those columns
change and then you have to rectify
which columns change which ones match up
with which and when you have a
spreadsheet that is just so enormous
that makes it almost impossible so yes
it's easier to have multiple
spreadsheets with different fields that
you can connect to each other than one
with all these columns that are also
referenced in the data dictionary yes
good good we're good all right so I
think you all are basically ready to
interrogate your data like a journalist
right you're going to gather it you're
going to vet it
again you write about it visualize it
it's going to be great
um we are available for the rest of the
day so please come and talk to us we
like people
thank you so much thank you